dans trois ans les paroissiennes et les
paroissiens de montigné voisins le
bretonneux pourront se retrouver dans ce
lieu plus de 250 personnes avaient fait
le déplacement pour découvrir les
esquisses définitive d'un projet qui
remonte à plus de dix ans un édifice qui
se voit et qui est
à la fois montre la prière l'accueil des
personnes qui sont chrétiennes ou qui ne
sont pas chrétienne un édifice des
chrétiens prient et se réunissent le
dimanche pour prier en semaine un projet
de 7,5 millions d'euros financés par le
diocèse de versailles et qui se voulait
participatif les gens ont été associés à
la définition du cahier des charges au
choix du nom à la discussion sur les
premières esquisses
donc les gens se prennent au jeu on peut
dire et ont envie que cette église soit
la maison de tous et qu'ils aient tous
pu participer à sa conception
une démarche qui a visiblement séduit
les intéressés qui approuve ce projet et
ses lignes modernes
je pense qu'aujourd'hui à l'église là
doit être tournée vers vers demain
et cette église est bien le reflet de à
la fois de la tradition l'église et en
même temps d'une église qui est tourné
vers l'avenir
ce qui me plaît c'est l'aspect
maternelle rond et les deux tantes qui
se rencontrent ça je trouve ça
extraordinaire
l'heure est désormais à la réflexion sur
la décoration intérieure les travaux eux
devraient commencer début 2019 pour une
ouverture prévue en 2020